Donald Trump last night in Pennsylvania
touting his economic successes and today
new economic numbers reveal the economy
is moving just look at some of these
statistics 157 thousand jobs were added
in July and the unemployment rate is
down to three point nine percent
Hispanic unemployment hit a new record
low in July earlier today President
Trump tweeted about the great economic
news writing quote July is just the
ninth month since 1970 that unemployment
has fallen below four percent our
economy is added 3.7 million jobs since
I won the election four point one GDP
more than four million people have
received the pay raise due to tax reform
400 billion dollars brought back from
overseas of course the left is trying to
figure out how to spin these great
economic numbers for Trump with some
Democrats even claiming that workers are
quote losing their jobs joining us now
is the author of why we fight Fox News
national security strategists Sebastian
Gorka and former Obama economic adviser
Austin Goolsbee Austin you know I want
to go to you first so ok ok so you
remember what he said to the inner city
to African Americans what do you have to
lose and now african-american
unemployment below us in history and I'm
not gonna repeat all the numbers please
tell me how you're gonna say Donald
Trump is not a good president at least
for the economy well I'm kind of
surprised that you're choosing today's
job number because today's job number
was actually a whiff was almost 40,000
below what was expected doesn't mean
it's not a plus 150 7,000 is OK now if
we have this conversation last Friday I
would be totally on board with you that
we had a great GDP jobs
okay job tonight but we're gonna have to
go after you okay Sebastian minute God
may just be happy for all Americans just
for once I mean really the New York
Times has to hire a racist for its
editorial board I get it but let's talk
about the economy let's get back into
the real world I've just read your new
book you know the president you've known
him a long time he wants success for all
Americans this is all the left doesn't
get I worked for him I took his the job
with him for one reason because he
doesn't care if you voted for him or not
you you could have wanted Bernie to be
president you may have voted for Hillary
but he wants you to succeed he wants you
to be safe and he wants you to prosper
that's the present and the left will
never believe it judge well let me ask
you this Austin when when the Democrats
start running and they're running now
obviously for 2018 which is why the
president has already started this push
I mean how did they do they just ignore
the economy or do they talk about maybe
Isis is coming back what do they say I
think what they would say is the numbers
you quoted where you said four million
people have gotten a raise there's 150
million workers in the country if you
look at job creation rates or wage
growth both of those have actually
slowed down in the 18 months that we've
been under Donald wait wait a minute oh
I think they'll probably highlight those
facts okay and and do you think that
America by not gonna let Sebastian
answer that but do you think America
agrees with Nancy about this just crumbs
it's just crumbs would they rather not
see extra money in their paychecks
that's the new Austin Austin oh I
thought you said Sebastian no I sound
more money in their paychecks they
haven't their corporate profits are at
record levels as a share of GDP and the
wage share of the economy is the lowest
that it's ever been okay let's get down
to Brussels should emphasize that growth
is fast and the Democrats will emphasize
that wages have not been going up but
they have God's the best so so I just
want to know what Austin and his cadre
say to the fact that we have the lowest
unemployment since record-keeping began
you can't spin that you can't say well
the growth has degenerated who cares
Austin we have oil companies Thanks
unleashing companies that are giving
twenty five thousand dollar signing
bonuses in America that is and that is
an economy unleash how can you not be
happy to see the unemployment figures
how can you we have basically functional
zero unemployment we have more jobs
available than people looking for jobs
how do you spin that Austin I had us
we've had a hundred and fifteen months
of private-sector job creation the
longest streak ever about eighteen of
those months were under Donald Trump and
all the rest were under brocco Obama
right right it's Obama totally for it
get three percent GDP growth either say
it again Austin point drop so you're
saying we don't have the opposite rate
of three percent so what's the latest
four point one percent figure that's
just fantasy for one core yet as you
know happen for different times under
brocco here's the problem Austin Barack
Obama had us convinced that one percent
GDP was the new normal those bozos
actually believe it now we're at four
point one you want to say it's maybe
it's less lately but I'm correct guys is
correct Sebastian thank yourself growth
permanently to be great